[Music]
welcome back so now I'm gonna tell you
about one of my favorite emerging
techniques in numerical linear algebra
namely a set of tools we call randomized
linear algebra and in particular I'm
gonna tell you about the randomized
singular value decomposition the
randomized SVD so you may have noticed
if you started computing the SVD on
larger and larger data sets that
although it is a fantastic tool for
crunching that data down into a low
dimensional representation for
extracting key features and patterns it
can be quite expensive you have to wait
around a while when this SVD is
computing on a large data matrix X now
increasingly what we have because of
cheaper sensors and the availability of
bigger and bigger data is higher and
higher dimensional measurements so the
measurement dimension is increasing
pretty rapidly for example just think
about your your phone your phone has
more megapixels now than it did last
year than it did the year before and the
year before and the year before this
video is being shot in 4k
whereas a year ago we just had an HD
camera so increasingly sensors are
becoming cheaper and cheaper and you're
getting higher and higher and higher
dimensional measurement data so I think
you know 4k soon it'll be 8k and so on
and so forth okay but the whole idea of
the SVD is that even given very very
high dimensional data there are a few
key patterns that exist in the data that
you care about or at least that's the
hope is that there are some patterns in
that data that you actually care about
for your kind of building models or for
understanding the data and so there may
still be a low intrinsic rank and what I
mean by intrinsic rank is there might be
a few key features in the data that
actually matter despite this increasing
measurement dimension if I take a
picture of a dog whether it's in HD 4k
or
kay there's still mostly the same
information if I want to crunch down and
compute this SVD okay and so there's
this emerging technique and randomized
linear algebra that essentially randomly
samples the column space of your matrix
X so you have your X matrix what we're
going to do is we're going to randomly
sample the column space and with high
probability so randomly sample the
column space and with high probability
we're going to find the subspace that
will be spanned by the dominant columns
of that u matrix from the SVD okay this
relies on high dimensional geometry some
of the same ideas from compressed
sensing and and high dimensional sparse
vectors and high dimensional geometry
that we'll talk about in Chapter three
this is all covered in section one point
eight of our book and data-driven
Science and Engineering the link is in
the the comments and in the next video
were actually going to code up this
randomized SVD on examples but here I
just want to go walk through the math of
how we can expect to make our lives
easier and compute a faster more
efficient SVD if there really is low
rank structure okay so the key
assumption is that there is in fact a
low intrinsic rank there is structure in
the matrix that I want to uncover even
if it's very very very high dimensional
okay and I'm gonna walk through this
both in math and in pictures I think
that'll be that'll be pretty helpful
okay so step one there's kind of two
steps to this this procedure of
computing this randomized SVD step one
we're going to compute a random
projection matrix P so we're going to
take a random projection and it really
is important that this is a random
matrix P that we can multiply on the
column space of X so we're gonna
multiply P is a matrix that is going to
be M by R where R is the target rank
of our system this is the the number of
columns of the singular value
decomposition that we actually want to
approximate so we want we want X is
approximately equal to u R sigma r v r
transpose where these are the first are
columns of u and v and the first r by r
sub matrix of sigma okay maybe r is 10
or 20 even though X is very very large
so we're going to build this random
projection matrix P and we're gonna
multiply x on the right by P and it's
gonna shrink the column space down from
m to R so M might have been a thousand
columns and R might only be ten modes
that we want so it's going to be a big
reduction in the column space and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
compute the QR factorization which is
pretty efficient in fact the QR
factorization is what we use to normally
compute the SVD of X in the first place
but now instead of computing it on X
we're going to compute it on Z and what
Q is going to give us is an orthonormal
basis an ortho normal basis for for Z
but also for X if this random projection
matrix really is random then with high
probability we're going to sample all of
the columns of X because we're getting
this random projection of all of those
columns of X and so Z and X are probably
going to have the same dominant column
space and that's going to be we're gonna
find an ortho and orthonormal
representation for that space using the
Q from this QR factorization okay and so
in pictures this is pretty easy to
picture we have our big X matrix this is
our input this is our big x matrix what
we're going to do is we're gonna
multiply it by a really really skinny P
matrix where P only has as many columns
as the rank that I want to capture this
is rank R then this is gonna have our
columns and it's gonna be much much
smaller
and that's gonna give me a skinny z
matrix that in principle because of the
properties of random vectors and high
dimensional geometry if I multiply this
by a bunch of random vectors in the
columns of P I'm gonna sample all of
that column space of X the dominant
column space of X is going to be
captured in Z and then I can find an
orthonormal representation for that
column space using the Q R factorization
okay
and again the QR factorization is what
we normally use to compute the SVD in
the first place but here we're applying
it to a skinny small matrix Z instead of
a big matrix X so it's a lot faster to
do it on Z than on X ok and it still
captures most of the same information
good that's step one now step two what
we're going to do is we're now going to
project our original data matrix X onto
that subspace Q we're gonna now that we
have an orthogonal subspaces face of Z
and X we're gonna project X into that
low dimensional subspace so now step two
is we're going to project project X into
Q or onto Q however you want to say it
down to the Q dimensional space so we're
gonna get this y equals Q transpose X
okay now this is much lower dimensional
it's gonna have a really small dimension
R and now we're going to compute the SVD
of this Y matrix okay so now we compute
the SVD of y equals and I'm gonna write
this as u sub y these are the single the
left singular vectors of the Y matrix
Sigma sub y and V sub y transpose but
here's the catch again and this this
requires some proof that I'm not going
to go into here but based on the
properties of random matrix theory and
structured matrices X the the Sigma and
the V of this small Y matrix should be
the same as the Sigma and the V of my
high dimensional X matrix because this U
is an orthonormal basis
spans the columns of X then this the
Sigma and V will be the same as for X
okay that's a key key property so now I
have my Sigma and my V all I have to do
is compute my my U for X based on my you
from Y okay that's the last step here
and so the last step is pretty easy you
just compute u u x equals Q times u Y
you just lift these small kind of size
or singular vectors back to this really
high dimensional n-dimensional space
through this Q matrix so this kind of
lifts it back to the space we want to be
in so these are the components that we
want for our rank our singular value
decomposition of X and again we can
write this kind of pictorially in terms
of matrices in the following way so now
I take my q transpose the skinny Q
transpose matrix and I multiply that by
my big X matrix and again this is all
still less expensive than computing the
SVD of X directly that gives me a Y
matrix which is a lot smaller so it's
size R by M this is my Y matrix I can
compute its singular value decomposition
and I get u I times Sigma Y times V Y
transpose these are the vectors I
actually want and then from this you why
I can compute u X which is equal to Q
times u Y ok so this is pretty cool
let's just do a recap that's a lot of
math for for a 10-minute video so the
recap here is that computing the SVD of
a big matrix X is very expensive if I
have
billion column if each column is a
billion dimensional and I have a million
of those columns this is a massive
massive matrix but if I believe that
there's low rank structure in there of
rank R let's say R is ten or a hundred I
can get away with massive reduction and
computation and still accurately
estimate that rank R singular value
decomposition by first taking a random
projection matrix P to go down to a low
dimensional space that should
probabilistically have the same kind of
the same rough column space as X the
same dominant column space as you are
and as X I can then find an orthonormal
representation using this QR
factorization and then I can work
entirely in those that basis given by Q
I can project X into Q to get Y I can
compute the SVD there and then I can
lift those singular values vectors back
up to the high dimensional space and
approximate the quantities that I
actually want okay so this is very very
useful technique in randomized numerical
linear algebra this is becoming pretty
standard in a lot of fields worth really
big data like fluid dynamics Facebook
and Google or using randomized SVG's now
because their data is so massive okay
good now there's a couple of things I'll
tell you about this is the vanilla
version of randomized SVD there's a
couple of techniques that make it a lot
more effective and efficient one is
called power iterations and the other
one is called over sampling over
sampling is pretty easy to to understand
we basically instead of measuring our
columns we just do our plus 5 or plus 10
and just by adding 5 or 10 extra random
projections we massively improve the
efficiencies re the the accuracy of this
algorithm ok so i'll tell you about
power iterations and over sampling next
thank you